[Musique]
si l'homme politique chinois le plus
puissant depuis Mao
ce congrès se déroule dit-il au moment
où le parti est la Chine sont engagés
sur la voie de la construction d'un pays
socialiste moderne
un pays où la politique draconienne de
covid 0 de confinement et de contrôle
des citoyens sera maintenu si j'ai une
ping la défunt vigoureusement
il affirme avoir rassuré la santé des
Chinois tout en protégeant le
développement économique la croissance
est cependant à son plus bas niveau en
près de 40 ans en Chine ce qui fait de
la stratégie sanitaire chinoise un pari
risqué selon cette
analysteusement de la population
augmentait si mais il y avait une
reprise du covid tout ça qui risque que
qui pèse sur l'avenir du système
politique en Chine si j'ai une fille
fustige par ailleurs les provocations
l'extérieur est-ce qu'il qualifie
d'ingérence étrangère à Taïwan la Chine
rêve d'annexer pacifiquement l'île
qu'elle considère être son territoire
mais le président chinois répète qu'il
n'exclut pas l'usage de la force quand
le peuple chinois doit résoudre la
question de Taïwan lance-t-il dans une
déclaration écrite le gouvernement
taïwanais répond que l'île est un État
souverain c'est d'effacer l'expérience
que représente aujourd'hui Taïwan
c'est-à-dire une société chinoise en
tout cas de culture chinoise
multiethniques qui a connu une dictature
extrêmement brutale mais qui s'est
démocratisée de l'intérieur
de quoi surprendre certains analystes si
Jinping n'a fait aucune mention de
l'Ukraine ou de la Russie dans son
discours de près de deux heures
la confirmation du troisième mandat
historique de sigin ping ainsi que la
composition du bureau politique du parti
communiste chinois devrait être annoncé
le lendemain de la conclusion du Congrès
la semaine prochaine il suffit Leblanc
Radio-Canada
[Applaudissements]